you know what i stopped comparing myself
i stopped comparing myself and you know
it's
been said that comparison is the thief
of joy
that is what instagram is that is what
social media it is literally and i
talked to my wife about this and i'm
like
she's like i don't follow people like
that you know i don't i i follow you
know
she's like in the science and she's much
smarter than i am and
you know she's like i don't follow that
sort of stuff i'm like there's no way
there's you don't just follow science
and
it's subconsciously we are seeing
a barrage of different people's
lives and i just think that there's
something innately in us
that we cannot help but compare on some
level it doesn't necessarily like
oh i want i want that car
it doesn't necessarily even happen like
that it happens in this very subtle way
that just gets at us and eventually
takes us out of the present
and takes away the joy and gratitude of
where we're at in our lives right now
you mentioned um spirituality and
you know knowing about your story and
the things that you've gone through
with addiction with success
um with humble beginnings with
paying record labels to put your song
out there which is brilliant
um do you feel uh
where does spirituality fit into all
that
um i think that spirituality for me
is crucial you know it's a huge part of
my recovery
it's uh it's what gets me out of self
right like when i wake up in the morning
um it's important to immediately remove
that self
will those desires that pop up in my
head like what do i want right now
what you know what do i need what am i
going to do today
um and gets me in a place of of
a little bit like let me be guided by
the spirit let me um
let me help somebody else and i think
that when i'm in those seasons in my
life where i feel that gratitude and i'm
intentionally taking the time because
you know i got two kids a busy life
um you know from the minute that i wake
up it's like bam dad mode you're on
when i take that time when i find those
moments to really get
centered um to do some prayers and
meditation
i find that my life is better
it just is there's something about it
that becomes
easier more fulfilling and i have more
gratitude
when i'm just running and gunning on
like what's next what do i want like
okay bam bam bam
i get a little bit off i get a little
bit off
i get i lose some of the
some of that perspective that i think is
so important and it all ties back into
spirituality for me
so it's an incredibly integral part of
my life
um did you grow up um did you grow up
with religion at all or is it
i grew up in a i grew up going to
catholic church i come from an irish
catholic family
um but that wasn't that's st patrick's
day
yeah yeah yeah but that wasn't where i
found
my spirituality from um that's where i
found you know
that was a i was a kid and by the time
that i was
15 my parents were like you know you can
make the choice
whether you're gonna go to church or not
and that's cool i was like
peace yeah i'm still on christmas
isn't that interesting i feel like a lot
of um
there's a lot of that there's a lot of
people that go to church growing up and
it's like
i don't i'm not i'm not i think it's i
think it has i
i subscribe to the uh religion that i've
at least seen on scene of definition of
omnism which is
that you don't believe in any one
religion but there's truth in all of
them
um so of course they're i think they're
all they all have roots of goodness but
you know then
man gets a hold of them and you know
figures out how to make money um but
but i feel like it's so common that
people have to heal from
religion completely i mean i definitely
when i first came into the rooms of
recovery i mean the word
god i was not comfortable with that word
at all
you know i had been um i had an
experience that i didn't resonate with
from the time that i was
you know i mean before i could remember
when i was baptized up until 15 that um
it wasn't a place that i found my
connection and that's not
that's just my experience that's not
against anyone else that
that finds their connection in a church
or a synagogue or mosque or anything
like that i think i agree with you
completely
the older that i get the more i became
removed from my actual upbringing with
the church the more that i could see the
truth
in religion and what i do think is
amazing about religion is that
it forms a sense of community um people
interaction humanity feeling
um you know being in the same place with
the same intention of connecting with
something that is greater than ourselves
that intangible
and that's super powerful that is really
powerful and it's
incredibly empowerful in in this day and
age
where we are we are so much on our
phones we are so
now we're on zoom you know we're not in
person
we're we're working from home we're not
around other people
and i think that that is a a very you
know
impaired part of the human experience to
be able to
get in a room with people and whether
that's in work whether that's in prayer
or worship
and and have like-minded intention
i think we're meant to be in community
right i mean that's we're not meant to
do this by ourself
and you know you've talked about how
important that community was
with recovery and realizing you're not
alone and
you know i've done this in my own life
where i realized that when i
am vulnerable enough to share the things
that are going on with me i give
people even if it's on a simple level of
like
i don't know not looking put together or
you know being uh making mistakes or
what it could be really simple it
doesn't have to be super big and
complicated
but i then give that person permission
to
show the same otherwise if i'm perfect
if i'm put together if i make no
mistakes that person does not feel any
comfort
to not look perfect to not make mistakes
and that's not living
no that's that's exactly you know
that gives it gives me some goosebumps
because that's exactly it
and that is and that is what for me
recovery is all about that's why it
works
it's because we come in there and we
share our struggles our experience and
our hope
and when you do that open openly and
honestly
with willingness to be open to
whatever's in the room and you just
share who you really are and where
you're at
that's where there's power that's where
that vulnerability is contagious and
that's what
that's where my best music has come from
that's when i've been the most tapped
into my spirituality
i'm not trying to project an image i'm
not trying to be performative i am
literally
just sharing where i'm at in the moment
in all its flaws and
imperfections um there is beauty and yet
we try to
we try to to hide that right because we
feel like we have to keep
up with everyone else and you know we
need to put the filter over our picture
and
you know everything needs to look
pristine and you've in in
what we really are craving is
that imperfection that is what makes us
feel human
and we feel seen when other people are
going through the same thing and we
become closer
as a community that's that magic